now let's get into the big story of uh
the day so far Southwest canceled more
than 2 000 weekend flights and the
disruptions are continuing this is story
this is a story from today it's been
update updated after I covered it this
morning but I also did something
interesting there was a there was a post
on patriots.win which is the big Donald
Trump forum and someone there said they
were a pilot and they were like Tim
Poole I know you you browse here you
know you better you know get get in
touch with me and then I was like okay
so I did a little digging found the
person's information turns out it wasn't
actually the person who was posting I'll
leave out a lot of details but with
someone related to a pilot with
Southwest who was relaying basically
their story and what I was told was
there's no strike there's no sick out
it's worse it is part of what we've been
seeing with the labor shortages across
the board when you push people too hard
eventually they reach their limit so the
vaccine mandates for instance was a huge
smack in the face to a lot of these
pilots who are already pushing their
maximum hours I'm being told that you
know back in August some of these people
were already told by the by the by the
FAA due to what they said Federal
Aviation regulations they couldn't fly
you fly too much they're being spread
too thin and we saw the same thing
happened earlier with Spirit Airlines so
we're seeing this across the board in
almost every industry with labor
shortages you add on top of the fact
that people are being spread too thin a
vaccine mandate this is this is just bad
policy across the board but I know uh
Utah we were talking about having gotten
a message from someone or having more
insight on this yeah so uh what happened
was that uh Colin is friends here with a
number of Southwest pilots and also in
my family I've got a pilot and an air
traffic controller and what happened was
is uh he got a text from one of his
Pilot buddies saying like hey there's uh
a walk out or you know when they say
walkout it's not a literal walk out it's
uh you know folks calling in sick at air
traffic controllers in Jacksonville it's
caused stopped like 650 flights more to
follow just wait the pilots are about to
step in too and it's just getting
started spread the word so then Colin
says well I know Tom's got a lot of
followers on Twitter you know for a
non-public figure and Tom knows people
who have an awful lot of followers on
Twitter and he says you want to put it
on us you want to put it out it says
Dave said go for it so I did and I was
actually in the air I was on the plane
on the way out here from California and
I'm immediately starting out retweets
and then I send it out to you know our
mutual friend Jack vasovich or slickter
all those guys and it gets what goes
Super viral it's I think we're like
almost 6 million views now it's insane
and we turns out like we we broke the
story We scooped everybody else which
sounds crazy and then it seemed crazy to
us at first because there was nothing
about it there's nothing anywhere we
were searching yeah he he tells me about
it like I'm not seeing anything about
that do you know anything I didn't see
anything in the media and so then it
goes big and next thing you know we're
I'm in the plane the entire way and and
it's just I'm getting DMS we're getting
hit up by people and then next thing you
know we hear about more and then more
and then I got a DM from somebody says
Hey Tucker Carlson would like to talk to
you and here's a number I'm like how do
I know is it a non-account I'm like how
do I know this is you know and he says
he will talk to you on the phone so I'm
like okay sure so I send like a you know
probing text like hello and then get a
phone call and hello hi Tom this is Doug
Carlson I'm like holy crap okay yes sir
yeah and so it was great so we talked
for about 20 minutes and I referred him
to a few of our friends who are pops who
spoke to and also spoke to the air
traffic control my family she is
unvaccinated and is planning on you know
losing her job yeah yeah and so they're
making plans and all that and but
everyone else yeah is that like
you know a thousand people out of fifty
thousand you know I think or is it six
thousandth number is that for
controllers that's the number I was
given yeah six thousand controllers were
gonna refuse vaccinations that's what
they're looking to lose that's that's
what I was given that's what and uh you
know who you are you're watching if you
want to text me and correct me go right
ahead but you know the total number of
air traffic controllers oh I don't know
I can actually find out I just found a
friend so uh yeah yeah so but that
friend of the family she's watching so
uh you go ahead and text me I mean
considering we're already dealing with
labor shortages and and problems with
flights as it is it's thousands no you
know small number yeah yeah I heard
Tucker Carlson might be having a pilot
on on his show today possibly but I
might have been the person introducing
yeah but this is this is severe we're
talking about 3.1 000 flights in four
days canceled yeah three thousand now
yeah 3.1 in four days now the union is
denying that this was a sick out but the
union the pilots Union Southwest Pilots
Union is actually suing Southwest
because on December 8th that is the
deadline that Southwest put on their
employees to get vaccinated or be fired
and you know this could have been
organized this could have not been
organized
um it's going to be playing out soon but
I definitely foresee this to become more
of the norm I'd see a lot more
disruptions coming uh former U.S
Congressman Ron Paul and former
presidential candidate Ron Pauls called
today the quote Great Rebellion so that
right there kind of solidifies this kind
of moment right now which everyone's on
edge everyone's waiting to see how these
mandates are going to play out other
people are calling some of these Pilots
terrorists some blue check mark uh
individuals on Twitter are saying the
pilots who are participating in a sick
out are terrorist and and then that's
just hyperbolic nonsensical language and
very interestingly even when we saw
Workers Union in Australia rise up we
saw a lot of people on The Establishment
left criticize them even though it was a
populist Workers Union standing up for
their personal freedoms for their bodily
autonomy for the their individual rights
as human beings not to be subjugated and
jumped through government Hoops so so a
lot of things are moving this is a fast
moving story it's only going to develop
from here and if it's not organized as
you said Tim this is only going to get
back get a lot worse and if it is being
organized I'm not going to say that it
is exactly they told us it was the
weather it's like it's the weather I'm
like full freaking crap oh the weather's
only affecting one Airline out of all
the other airlines out there you got to
be kidding me I mean we're not that
stupid Southwest released that statement
the mainstream media regurgitated it I
mean what kind of bullcrap are they
trying to give to the American people
when they're telling everyone it's the
weather guys oh crap here's the best
part so uh the other night we were
watching Family Guy like a new episode
and Fox 5 I don't know like the local DC
Channel or whatever the news comes on
and the big story is Southwest
cancellations at this point was over a
thousand and the lady said Southwest has
canceled over a thousand flights they
said in a statement that it was due to
weather and issues with air traffic
control the FAA issued a statement
saying that there was no shortage of air
traffic controllers or and then I was
like wait wait
who said shortages like why did they
include that statement so what you learn
is the news the news Outlet knew that
there was a story about a shortage
and they included the quote from the
from the FAA but not the actual
information the context you needed to
understand why the FAA said that right
what that says to me is the news
is withholding information from people
because they don't want here's what I
think I think if regular people realize
that 6 000 air traffic controllers are
going to refuse to be vaccinated and it
looks like from the FAA 14 000 air
traffic controllers in the U.S 14 000
plus that's yeah that's true consider
air travel done but if that's the case
how many more people are going to be
alike if they can do it so can I yeah
that's why they're so worried about
these celebrities too yeah I mean stare
down though too that's the thing right
now you're having you know establishment
whether this is like a major corporation
whether it's a government agency and you
got the people and like they're having
the stare down like hey somebody's gonna
have to Blink yeah from somebody else
but it's not just it's not just
Southwest there's other elements of
society that are saying no no no no no
my body my choice I get to decide what I
get to put inside of myself including
Amtrak the Amtrak uh official Twitter
account just posted that there's going
to be some shortages of trains because
of quote unforeseen crew issues yeah
what unforeseen crew issues are you
talking about there's also Kyrie Irving
an NBA player that gets paid 50 15.58
million dollars he's putting his
contract on the line because he's
refusing to bow down to the
authoritarians and they're telling him
you might not be able to play home games
and that's what might happen in just a
few moments from now so and it's also
National Guardsmen there's there's also
reports of over a hundred thousand
troops not taking the vaccine not
budging so so there's there's a lot more
people out here that are saying no than
than we even know about here's what I
think we're seeing right now it's um we
we've talked about quite a bit the rat
experiment the rat Utopia experiment
what was it Carl Carl schlichter is that
the name of the guy so uh we went
through how long like a year of lockdown
a little bit longer and then it was this
summer they said okay everything's going
back to normal and then it's all coming
back again are you guys I'm sorry not
the rat Utopia experiment the The Hope
experiment sorry yeah are you guys
familiar with the Hope experience not
terribly no no they take three cylinders
they put rats in them they're full of
water and the Rats swim desperately
after 15 minutes the rats give up and
die they then did another experiment
they put the rats in the cylinders after
15 minutes the rats give up but then
they pull the rats out dry them off let
them rest put them back in then the rats
swam for 60 hours 6-0 yeah six zero
because they felt hope they were like I
will that hand will save me again that
was uh that's Dr Kurt Richter out of
here
that's what I think you know look these
these cancellations and everything it is
going to get bad the lockdowns are like
the vaccine minutes are basically
lockdowns they're telling businesses you
can't operate you know unless you do
these things and then we're seeing
people say no to them which is resulting
in more economic Strife but this time
people aren't going to freak out as much
they're gonna they're gonna hold out for
Hope because they've seen the return to
normal if only for a few months
that's a great observation I mean that
that experiment is terrifying uh
especially with what what could possibly
happen here because there's still a lot
of unexplained issues we still don't
know exactly what's going on we know
that there's a lot of mandates a lot of
government pressure we saw what happened
with United Airlines with them
pressuring their employees firing their
employees so I I could I could
definitely see that this is not going to
go away anytime soon but there's also a
lot of other issues you know there's
there's estimates here that over 100
million people in the United States had
already coveted uh this brings up the
question of natural immunity there's 200
million estimated people that have taken
the vaccine but daily cases are still up
300 percent than they were from last
year when there was no vaccine what's
going on here what's the science Dr
fauci deserves to explain all of this
and there's no explanation there's no
conversation and we should at least
start with some of these basic facts and
just be able to have an honest real
conversation about it and we can't I
think we need to recognize that they
don't know yeah and the problem is Dr
fauci likes to always say definitive
things and then get proven wrong and
then probably one of the most dangerous
things he said was Christmas is canceled
and then everyone's like freaking out
and then he goes I misread the science
it's not canceled anymore like then
don't say it yeah because people are
freaking out already but hey maybe
that's what they want who loves the
attack
exactly and that's why when there was a
major backlash he went back on the
science of canceling Christmas and just
a few months ago he issued a statement
that he's granting permission for kids
to go trick-or-treating are you kidding
me you're not you're not the you're not
God you might be compared to Keebler
elves but but but that's not God and it
may be in some religions it is but but
but for Frick thank you Lord God Emperor
like you don't get like like there's no
science back to by it it's all
popularity contest and it's getting
ridiculous by the day isn't he the
highest paid federal employees yeah he
is he's making more money than like the
president yep making more than like a
four-star general because he I think
he's been in that job that specific job
like as long as like someone's been
alive longer than I've been alive yeah
I'm curious to know all these good
streams he has oh yeah oh yeah book deal
he's got that Netflix documentary too no
Disney
right thank you
to the new movie fauci had like a 1.2
rating on uh IMDb but it was a bunch of
fraudulent reviews so now they're fixing
as a five-point rating sure they're like
let's be real you can hate fauci the
story can be awful but we put that
documentary together very well yeah how
many dislikes does it have now because
they got rid of the comments I want to
see I'm going to look it up it was 95
000 dislikes uh a couple days ago let's
actually can we yeah where's that on
YouTube it's on YouTube it's it's the
fauci Disney plus trailer to his
documentary that's a horrible picture of
it it's Disney plus with National
Geographic like I don't know if he's got
if he had a cheekbones done or something
so so we pulled it up a hundred and five
thousand dislikes oh my so the National
Geographic page are you on that one oh
no I'm on on Disney plus yeah the fauci
official trailer has 21 000 dislikes on
the National Geographic one which comes
up first when you type in fauci National
Geographics documentary that was
released a month ago a hundred and five
thousand dislikes 7.7 we got it right
here 105
000 dislikes
wow yeah yikes man this is popular well
I'll tell you this people don't like uh
Dr fauci yes
man I know I mean who's gonna Who's
Gonna Love North Korean style propaganda
films seriously I mean there's no
conflict there's no drama here there
it's Bono and George W bush acting like
fluffers to Dr fauci that's what the
documentary is about okay I don't want
to watch that if I want to watch North
Korean style propaganda movies I'll
watch North Koreans propaganda movies
they're funny
at least there's there's something there
that you know is kind of theater but for
them to play like they're unbiased and
not interview anyone critical of them
not introduce any I mean they talk about
the the age drama a little bit but but
other than that it's just glorification
of a government bureaucrat and there's
nothing more disgusting in my opinion
than to worship someone in in in public
office you should be holding them
accountable you should be uh making sure
that they're transparent you should be
making sure that they're accountable to
the people you should be making sure
that they're working for you not
worshiping and celebrating these I
so so hold on don't don't show it just
yet but I pulled up the Rotten Tomatoes
for fauci and um do you guys have a
guess a guess on the the official critic
score 99.99 yeah first official oh don't
look at the screen I already gave you my
guess I said 99.9 all right just pull it
up the the official critics give fauci
91 wow but the audience score is two
percent oh my gosh this is like the
worst score I've ever seen from an
audience but it's it's people who just
don't like vouching yeah we didn't have
that audience score we should pull up
the Dave Chappelle uh recent comedy that
was actually I I saw half of it I was
actually pleasantly surprised it was I
didn't agree with everything he said but
it was it was good I I enjoyed it I was
able to sit back and enjoy it now we
pull up Dave Chappelle the closer
official critics 33 audience score 90
seven percent you see how this works oh
yeah they're they're there are uh
clearly two different
um figurative species the journalists
yeah the the the better men as they
would call themselves or better yes our
betters and then everyone else right and
they're all sitting there clapping off
ouchie he's brilliant and Dave Chappelle
how dare he oh it's digital Hunger Games
you know what I mean in a lot of ways
very I mean it's not fortunately it's
not real Hunger Games no no we're not
there yet it almost is I mean with like
AOC at the Met Gala wearing that dress
no masks and then we see that what was
it a Seth Rogen at the at the Emmys I
think where he's like look at us all
we're not wearing asks he's like what's
wrong with us and they're all laughing
about it like they don't care this makes
me think that it makes me cement the
idea that authoritarianism doesn't work
in art because you can't like force
someone to think they like something
they don't like but then I'm thinking
about you and me Park coming out of
North Korea and how they don't even know
what love is like they don't understand
that concept because it was never taught
to them so maybe authoritarianism does
work in art and we're just seeing the
beginning of them trying to do it and it
doesn't work in the beginning well it's
a generation look at all these movies
where they did like woke remix or
whatever I mean man I know you guys
haven't seen the new craft because of
just you know who you are as people who
pay attention and can have good taste
but you guys you guys remember craft
right the old 90s movie with the
Witchcraft thing yeah
so they remake it okay and the latest
version is just like the most
nonsensical woke religious garbage it's
not even a movie it's just like doesn't
make sense at all David Duchovny for
some reason turns out to be the bad guy
but he like he apologizes to this girl
for being mean with her you know mean to
her she's she's the stepdad and he's
like don't attack people because she hit
somebody and then she gets all like
shocked that she was told not it just
the movie makes literally no sense they
cast a spell and I gotta turn him gay or
something for real is it worse than girl
Ghostbusters
oh yeah yeah yeah okay yeah at least
girl Ghostbusters was like just a bad
movie sure the craft is like random woke
PSA Clips stitched together yeah and so
you know like what you're saying Ian you
can't force someone to like art yeah but
if that's like if there are people who
will just clap you know in unison for
the establishment it's not about liking
art it's about just they're clapping to
fit in and so they'll tell you they like
everything they like anything they're
told to like yeah the comments on this
Dr fauci documentary are absolutely
glorious and uh stunning someone wrote
uh corporations and government working
together against the people classic
another person wrote the gain of
function is really going to be relatable
to a lot of people so and someone
someone wrote that they're gonna make
this movie into a ride at Disney and the
weight is going to be two minutes but
you're going to be in you're gonna be
there for 15 years
so the comments are absolutely beautiful
and uh glorious some people wrote this
is the sequel to Nuremberg 2.0 again A
lot of people are saying a lot of
different comments lots of uh let's go
Brandon's but uh the comments are very
entertaining to say the least nice so I
I I I think you know why didn't Trump
fire the guy yeah that's a very good
question why didn't Trump fire a lot of
people you know I think the reality is
the Trump presidency was was anything
but a despotism it was a guy who was
like I'm gonna do what I want to do and
he's kind of a loudmouth but he didn't
push too hard and the problem was he
should have fired a lot of people he
should have fired fauci but he didn't do
it he could have done it yep I think
right now as it stands like the odds are
if you play the odds I mean a lot of
people have these predictions but one I
mean it's pretty clear that Trump he's
going and I mean he's going for it this
this next round and frankly
I think he's gonna get it I'm not saying
this is one of those things where you
know whether it's essentially what I
want like and all that but I I if I had
to put bet money on something and I
think he's gonna win I really do I know
it sounds crazy right but I mean people
thought it was crazy the first time
around his his approval is up in rural
areas yeah we're hearing uh Suburban
areas that where anti-trump are now
supportive of trump even though he's not
president this is the craziest thing
it's like approval now flipped over 50
in some Suburban areas where they're
it's like he's not even the president
and they approve the guy what yeah and
he's going to go against like an
animated corpse
or are you gonna go against a very
unlikable you know former cop yes
or maybe he's going to go up against
Oprah but more importantly he's probably
going to have to go against Ron DeSantis
and there's a lot of Donald Trump
supporters that are absolutely angry at
him for his handling of of the events
after his presidency for not supporting
them for not standing up with them for
raising a lot of money and then kind of
sitting on it there's a lot of
accusations of of money just being
thrown away I don't disagree so so
there's a lot of disenfranchise Donald
Trump supporters that are absolutely mad
with him especially with what he did to
whistleblowers especially the
opportunities he had the opportunity
failed I mean if someone I I mean a lot
of people have been left after the Trump
presidency being like wait what just
happened yeah why oh yeah I thought he
was going to fake America a lot of
people are disenfranchised but a lot of
people are also understanding how bad
Biden is yeah so it's going to play off
and with the desantises uh you know
unfortunately his wife came down with
cancer breast cancer that's a that could
be a game changer for it because if
things take a turn like him doing
something like that while wife with
cancer if you're listening looking
fasting you know what I I think I think
uh Trump was heavily focused on his
economic agenda and he ignored the
politics of it all yeah that's kind of
the problem of having someone that a
non-politician is President exactly yeah
there I was talking to somebody a long
time ago in New York and they were they
were mentioning I think Philadelphia
they had I don't know it's not a wolf is
it but they mentioned they tried
electing a businessman governor and it
didn't work or something I don't know
the full details maybe you guys in
Pennsylvania know this but typically
what you'll get is someone like Trump
who thinks that he you know he's the CEO
of this big company he can be like
you're fired then he gets in the
government and he goes somebody and says
you're fired and they go uh you don't
have the authority to do that that's got
to go through committee approval we'll
see you in a month yeah and that person
stays in the job or they got a weird
Federal Union so I feel like Trump
mostly I mean he picked a lot of weird
culture war fights he focused on
economics which was was good but they
they the swamp had him surrounded yeah
you know he couldn't actually change
things that needed to be changed I mean
if the one thing he could have done was
I don't know pardon Assange sure
couldn't even do that he he pardons the
Detroit mayor he said he doesn't know
who Assange is he said he loved
Wikileaks when he was running for
president and then he's like Wikileaks
what's that I don't even know what that
is like what are you doing like you have
an opportunity and chance to to go
against the establishment in such a way
with just one little move correcting or
wrong by the U.S military industrial
complex correcting a wrong by the
Intelligentsia and you don't do it but
he fire fouchy like you know even when
he was not clearly not getting along
with the guy right yeah but I you know
he just he didn't make these moves and
you know if you think about this like uh
I know you've had I'm sure you guys are
all familiar with Curtis yarvin of
course and one thing he's talked about
quite a bit where it's like hey this is
bigger than one man you know where it's
like you know we're like the president
United States is like the leader of the
executive branch in the same way that
the Queen of England is like the head of
state for yeah officially I say but
doesn't have any real concert Social
Power has a little bit like on paper but
isn't really anything he did a big long
bit I'm a big fan of his and he did a
long bit on Tucker Carlson today
explaining all that I hope you guys get
him on I mean he is he's he's fantastic
but he's just like no it's bigger than
him it's like you look at the entire
federal government where it's just like
it's like fish in a coral reef and then
a giant wave goes over a hurricane
it is yeah and the fish are just kind of
like you know the actual federal
employees there's like oh what's
something you know every election
something happened where it's like it's
bigger like that's you know and we call
that people call that deep State or the
swamp but it's decentralized it's not
some cabal the administrative State yeah
Administration yeah exactly
decentralized all that right these
people who exist in government Beyond
you know in between every Administration
sure they just they never go and then
they they influence Intel yeah and
you'll get a president who comes in and
the same people back here's your
official report and I think this time or
last time with Trump trump was like I
don't care America First and they were
like oh he's not listening to us what do
we do and then all of a sudden they were
like uh he just got elected and we'll
impeach him yeah the same people who
said they were gonna started the process
yeah you're for those recommendation of
that book that machiavellians would be
really good for Trump to read if he
comes back in again because I think the
real question is what does he do
differently I don't know if you read
books yeah I I know hold on hold on yes
please if Tucker reads it oh yeah oh
yeah there you go then Trump will turn
on his you know Fox News and then Tucker
will say it and then we're good as long
as you know but uh
that's good things about this I should
listen thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time